thanks for stopping by i appreciate you
and congratulations on all things at
this point thank you very much i want to
talk about the black panther moment
there was a big hug on stage was
extremely emotional what can you tell me
about that i mean i feel like chadwick
is pulsing through these people a bit he
is and ryan coogler had some beautiful
words at the top of the panel and about
feeling chad on his shoulders still the
last time we were all together on that
stage chad was with us um and it was
beautiful and it's a you know it's a
very um
important thing that wakanda forever not
only brings the same level of joy and
inspiration that the first black panther
film did but it also is a tribute to
what he did and what chad brought to the
not just to us but to the world
it really was on that stage and we and
we knew and we knew it would be um and
it was a beautiful
it was a beautiful moment seeing seeing
that and with our guardians cast and our
and our ant-man cast and she-hulk cast
it really is very lucky that it's a uh
everybody loves what they do
because we get to do cool stuff so why
wait like it's fun it's hard but it's
fun you've released up to i believe
phase six what what made you decide to
you know kind of let out all this
information now well you know we've
we've we're in a slightly different
rhythm now the the phase one two and
three were less projects over more years
now we're doing more projects with with
all the amazing series we're able to do
in disney plus over less years and felt
like we were not each phase wouldn't end
in an avengers movie and it felt like we
needed to let people know people used to
have that guide point of when an
avengers would come to cap the face it
felt like announcing today that the
multiverse saga and two avengers films
would cap that was something that that
that we needed to share oh my goodness
yeah thank you for sharing it and dude
literally congrats all the way around
you guys are crushing it and don't stop
because we need this to exist forever
thank you very much sir appreciate it
[Music]
you